In this final segment, we want
to discuss an interesting point
about linear estimators.
Here's what the issue is.
You obtain an observation,
X, on the basis
of which you want
to estimate Theta.
But perhaps you measure
X on a different scale,
let's say on a cubic scale, so
that what you record actually
is X cubed.
So you're faced with two
possible estimation problems.
One estimation problem is
to use X to estimate Theta.
Another estimation problem is to
use X cubed to estimate Theta.
Does it make a difference?
Let's consider the case of
least mean squares estimation,
without any
linearity constraint.
If you use X to estimate
Theta, your estimator
is going to be this
conditional expectation.
If you use X cubed
to estimate Theta,
your estimator will be this
conditional expectation.
Are they different?
Well, X and X cubed carry the
same information about Theta.
In particular, the posterior
distribution of Theta given X
is going to be the same as the
posterior distribution of Theta
given X cubed.
You will be getting
the same information,
the same knowledge about X.
And in particular,
if you calculate
conditional expectations,
these will also be the same.
What about the linear case?
If we restrict to
linear estimators,
then on the basis
of X, you would
form a linear
estimation of this kind.
But if your observation
is in the form of X cubed,
then a linear
estimator would form
a linear function of X cubed.
So this would be a
different kind of estimator.
We have seen a formula
on how to obtain the best
estimator, the best
choices of a and b
for estimators of this kind.
We can use that same
formula to obtain
the best estimator of that kind.
It's going to be, of course,
a different estimator.
Here, we're optimizing
within a different class.
Which one of the two is better?
Well, this depends
on what you know
about the particular
problem at hand.
If you have some
reason to believe,
or if you know that Theta
and X are roughly related
by some kind of cubic relation,
then perhaps estimators
in this class are going to
perform better than estimators
in that class.
Let me also point out a related
issue that would come here.
To find the right
choice of a, you
need to know the covariance
between X and Theta.
That's why the
formula tells us about
the optimal linear estimator.
Here you would you need to know
the covariance between Theta
and X cubed.
In addition, the formula
requires the variance of X.
But here, instead of
X, we're using X cubed.
So in this case, we would
need the variance of X cubed.
Now, this could be
more challenging.
In general, the higher
the powers that you have,
the more difficult
these quantities
are to calculate or
to know what they are.
But leaving that issue
aside, what we have here
is two alternative choices for
the structure of the estimator
that we're using.
Now, we can push
this story further.
Instead of considering just
estimators of this kind,
we might consider as well
estimators of this kind.
Is this a linear estimator?
We still call it a
linear estimator,
because it is linear
in the coefficients
that we have to choose
on how to optimize.
That's the more important part.
It's the linearity in these
coefficients that's important,
rather than the
linearity in the X's.
So as a function of
X, this is non-linear.
On the other hand, we can think
of this X as one observation,
X squared as
another observation,
X cubed as a third observation,
and what we've got here
is a linear function of
three different observations.
So we can still pose a least
squares problem in which we
try to find the best choices
for the coefficients a1, a2,
and a3, as well as
the coefficient b,
find those choices
that they're going
to give us the smallest
possible mean squared error.
So we can optimize
within this class.
Within this class of
estimators, we certainly
have more flexibility.
This is a more general
class of estimators
than either of this
one or that one.
So within this class, we should
be able to do even better.
On the other hand, we
would have to pay a price
that this is a more
complex structure.
It would be more difficult to
find the optimal coefficients.
And also, we're going to
need higher order moments
or expectations related
to the X's and the Thetas.
Finally, there's nothing
special in us using powers of X
and using a polynomial.
We could also look
at estimators that
have some other
type of structure.
For example, we
might want to mix
an exponential function in X
and a logarithmic function of X,
look at estimators of this form,
and try to choose the best one.
Find the best choice
of the coefficients.
Again, this is something
that is possible.
And again, it's
going to boil down
to solving a system of linear
equations in the coefficients.
On the other hand, we need
to know various expectations
about X that might be
difficult to obtain.
How do we choose
which structure to use
should it be this one, this
one, this one, or that one?
There's a trade-off, that
more complicated structures
introduce more
complexity and make
the problem more difficult.
But there's also another issue.
It has to do with
what do we know
about the particular
problem at hand.
If we know or have reason
to believe that third order
polynomials are going to give
us excellent estimates of theta,
then we may want to
work within this class.
In any case, the
moral of this story
is that if we are to use the
linear estimation methodology,
we do have some choices.
Linear in what?
And different choices will
give us different performance.
But this now gets somewhat
away from the subject
of a mathematical methodology,
and it gets closer to the art
that you need to exercise in
any particular problem domain.